ryan is with us in starkville
mississippi hi
ryan how are you good how are you dad
better than i deserve what's up
so me and my fiancee are both 22 years
old
graduating college both from mississippi
state at the end of the month wonderful
what are your degrees in
i'm in construction management and she
is elementary ed
excellent when are you getting married
uh
november or september 10th good for you
glad you got i'm glad you got it
straight
yeah all right september 10th big day
man congratulations
i appreciate it my question is
so neither of us will have debt my
parents helped me pay
my way through college and she
had a full-ride scholarship through
excellent teaching program
so she just has to teach mississippi for
five years after graduation
um we'll have just under a hundred
thousand dollars of joint income
once we're married um
and i will both be living with family so
very low expenses till then so plan on
saving
as much as we can until we're married
our question is do we need to
look at renting as our first housing
option or should we look at buying since
we're both debt
free and have that leg up on song
well you financially meet the guidelines
that we give you for buying we tell you
to be debt-free have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
before
you buy and then buy a 15-year mortgage
with a payment no more than a fourth
of your take-home pay on a fixed-rate
15-year mortgage
that's the guidelines that we use now i
will tell you
as a a dad of 20-somethings and
30-somethings
and has having coached folks for 30
years
i personally think you will make a much
better housing decision
if you wait one year and so i would be
per i would be looking for homes uh this
time next year
into the summer with the idea of closing
in september
one year on your one year anniversary
give or take it takes about a year
of living together as a married couple
to know how close to your mother-in-law
to buy
[Laughter]
you have to get you have to get to know
each other to make a better decision
right now there's a lot of wonderful
milestones happening in your life
you know you would not be human if you
didn't have stars in your eyes
uh you know you're getting married
you're graduating you both got good
careers you're debt-free man what a
wonderful
start you've got yes everything's great
here
it's not going to kill you if you buy a
house but i think you'll buy a different
house
one year from marriage than you would
have today
and if you start your real estate career
at 23
24 years old instead of 22 years old
that is
not the end of the world you are still
going to be wealthy you're still going
to be fine you haven't thrown the money
away
you've just concentrated on your
marriage spend the first year
concentrating on your marriage 100
don't there's an old thing in the old
testament in the bible that
they they would not allow a soldier to
go to war
in the first year of marriage and the
first year of marriage they had to stay
home and get the home solid before they
went off to war of course they were
often gone
for years at a time when they went off
to war but so it's a little different
but
but it's a it's a principle coming out
of uh second kings
ryan here's a little secret that when
you become a homeowner you start owning
problems that happen with that home
and i think that dave has nailed this i
think that in addition to what he said
is
to have a year of just renting a nice
apartment you guys can afford it and
enjoy
just living together and learning what
kind of a home do we want and as david
said
uh so beautifully there that that is
going to become more clear
uh a year later but you know you don't
need the additional stress
that comes with marriage uh dealing with
new jobs
new jobs new marriage we're sharing
silverware and mustard yeah come home
hang out at the pool at the apartment
complex be young and married with no
kids and chill
and just not have to think about you
know the gutters the gutter doesn't
agree with that
heat and air is not working that's what
nobody tells you you got to put up
curtain rods which
that by the way is the third largest
cause of divorce yes
true but um that's true
[Laughter]
because here's why in in in stacy's
house
her dad did it this is a true story my
wife we've been married almost 23 years
in my house and he knew how to run a
screwdriver he knew how to do it well
something that something i do something
mr coleman might not know how to do
no talent in that area but you do you
learn those things what time do we eat
dinner
i used to eat dinner this time in my
house who does what my dad used to fill
the dishwasher you know
who knows you got all these cultures you
roll the toothpaste or squeeze it yeah i
mean there's a lot of major
philosophical things that have to be uh
are you and sharing an alignment on how
to handle the tube of toothpaste this is
what people want to know
yeah you are yeah we each have our own
and separate ends
of that massive master bedroom bathroom
that's the right answer that's where we
had to go
and that way she doesn't get in my way
right
right yeah you know that's how it went
down
yeah i didn't want to agree with that no
you better not no
uh you me stacy will all be in trouble
uh so yeah you're that but i mean it's
it it's a
there is nothing wrong with and you're
gonna ryan you're gonna get tremendous
pressure from all these financial
geniuses that aren't
you know you're just throwing your money
away you need to go bye bye bye
bye bye and it's okay yeah i'm not
suggesting you go a decade without home
ownership i'm talking about 12 freaking
months
and let this thing have a little breathe
a little rhythm
to it and that's just an opinion and
it's probably worth what you paid for it
but i feel pretty strongly about that i
tell young couples
that are getting married wait at least a
year to buy a home
you got enough other things you got to
adjust in your life to get square on